нарешті те про що запекла дискутували ще
з літа сталося бойові танки леопард-2
таки вирушать в Україну
це результат інтенсивних консультацій з
нашими союзниками та міжнародними
партнерами І я хотів би наголосити що ми
правильно зробили Що не дозволили
підганяти себе а зосередилося на тісній
співпраці у цьому питанні і будемо
продовжувати це робити
на першому етапі Берлін планує надати
рото леопардів зі складів бундесверу це
попередньо 14 танків інші європейські
партнери з так званої танкової коаліції
також Мають передати Києву своїх
леопардів Німеччина дає дозвіл на
реекспорт це означає що ще 14 танків
леопард-2 Україні має передати Польща
Нідерланди розглядають можливість
передачі Україні 18 танків леопард-2 Для
цього вони готові викупити орендовані у
Німеччини бойові машини Іспанія
Португалії Норвегія Фінляндія та інші
Європейські країни також можуть
долучитися до танкової коаліції крім
леопардів в Україні пообіцяли й інші
сучасні західні танки Великобританія
надасть 14 бойових танків челенджер-2
Франція 14 Танків лікерк а США Як
очікується щонайменше 30 танків Абрамс
за оцінками експертів загалом йдеться
про понад сотню танків
це не та кількість яку просили Україна
їй потрібно було 300 сучасних бойових
танків тож кількома десятками можна
створити лише локальну перевагу над
російськими військами щоб підтримати
один або два наступи меншого масштабу
Отже ця кількість танків може становити
свого роду клейн вістря атаки але це не
та кількість яка рішуче змінила б хід
війни
окрім навчання як користуватися цими
надзвичайно складними дуже сучасними
системами Існує кілька логістичних
проблем одна з них пов'язана з вагою цих
машин
танк леопарда більш ніж у півтора рази
важчий за будь-які інші Танки які
використовує Україна тож це створює
проблеми для мостів транспортних систем
доріг особливо ґрунтових тож Попереду ще
кілька викликів проте зважаючи на досвід
отриманий з іншими переданами
українізахідними системами озброєнь і
напрочуд ефективну здатність українців
швидко вчитися використовувати їх
належним чином і насправді цілком
впевнений що ці логістичні проблеми з
танками також можна вирішити
Леопард 2 важить 60 тонн і може вражати
цілі на відстані до 5 км при цьому сам
він добрий захищений завдяки характерні
клиноподібні башті та якості броні крім
того Леопард дуже маневрений і легко
керується сучасні оптика тепловізори
гармати та кулемети забезпечують високі
бойові показники танка леопард
вважається одним з найкращих в своєму
роді і є на озброєнні в багатьох інших
країнах загалом вироблено понад 3500
танків Леопард 2 у свою чергу М1 Абрамс
- це основний танк армій США як і
німецькі Леопард 2 - це один із
найсучасніших бойових танків на ньому
встановлена 120-міліметрова
гладкоствольна громада а також три
кулемети різного калібру танк уснащений
комп'ютерною системою керування вогнем з
лазерним далекоміром Та тепловізором він
покритий композитною бронею зі сталі
кераміки та кевлару недоліком танків М1
Абрамс є те що вони складні
обслуговуванні є над важкими мають
високі витрати палива крім того він
споживає не дизель а дорожчі авіаційний
керосин важкі бойові танки на кшталт
леопардів чи абрамсів можуть мати
вирішальне значення Для успішного Контр
наступу ЗСУ вони дозволять Україні краще
реалізувати воєнну тактику НАТО згідно з
якою на полі бою взаємодіють одразу
кілька видів військ
замовстимс Найголовніше я вважаю що ці
танки мають кращу броню однак Ми також
повинні мати на увазі те що ці машини не
бачили багато битв і тому я змішані
відчуття попри дивовижні технічні
характеристики якими вони можуть
похвалитися в Сирії вони були вразливі
домін і мінометів тому ми не які саме
танки отримує Україна діти саме версію
леопардів і наскільки їх можна
порівнювати з тими що були на озброєнні
в Туреччини однак Незалежно від того чи
була модернізована броня Україна отримає
кращий захист екіпажу своїх танків
Protection
щодо надання леопардів канцлера
Німеччини Олафа Шульца критикували як
опозиція так і партнери по коаліції
після того як канцлер оголосив ухвалений
щодо леопардів рішення у бундестазі
лунали не лише Оплески але й критика
хотів би зазначити що на шляху до цього
Рішення було завдано значної шкоди Лише
кілька днів тому ми були у відкритій
суперечці з урядами країн Балтії з
Фінляндії
поляки на своє запитання чи можуть вони
поставити танки отримали бюрократичну
відповідь замість простого Так
це значні політичні збитки завдані
Німеччині хто несе за це
відповідальність
[музика]
незмінними рішеннями можна було
ухвалювати лише спільної союзниками
зокрема і США Німеччина не могла
дозволити собі одноосібних кроків у
постачанні важкої зброї на думку
опитаних ДВ експертів Росія не може дати
симетричну відповідь на леопарди
Росія в резерві не має сучасних танків
які зараз можна було б розгорнути на
лінії фронту Росія вже надіслала туди
все що може офіційна Москва говорить про
використання бойових танків т-14 Армата
хоча насправді аромата ще не готова
бойові тести не завершені і на цей
момент вироблена лише два десятки таких
танків
мета союзників України якомога швидше
зібрати два танкові батальйони леопардів
для України це приблизно 80 пансорників
підготовку українських екіпажів має
розпочатися вже найближчим часом у
Німеччині на додаток до навчання
військову допомога також включатиме
логістику боєприпаси та технічне
обслуговування систем рішення Німеччини
спонукає також інші держави Європи на
кшталт Швейцарії яка досі і
підкреслювала свій нейтралітет і не
давала дозвіл на реекспорт Швейцарського
озброєння також переглянути свою
політику щодо надання зброї України
після танкової дискусії Україна ініціює
також дебати щодо так званої авіаційної
коаліції з надання Україні сучасних
літаків таких як f-16